Yeah, yeah. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and today we are desperately seeking symmetry.
[inaudible] thus far we are failing desperately because maybe, maybe, you know,
if we took,
if we rejiggered our whole approach because symmetry know is really about love.
No, it's, it's what, even though we're changing the subject now,
it's about the way things look when they're flipped around or turned or rotated.
And this is where it gets really interesting. Reflected, reflected, yes.
Reflected because there was a map afflicted. Yes.
There was a mathematician at Oxford University named Charles Latoya. AJ Datsun.
There's a mathy named for you. Well, he had a different name as it happens.
Let Lewis Carroll. Oh, like the Alison Wonderland, the Alice in wonderland.
Dude, he is a mathematician. He was, I had really didn't know that.
Did you know that he wrote another book called through the looking glass?
Truthfully, I didn't know there were different books, you know,
very little in this particular [inaudible] but there's a part of the book where
Alice is standing in her room talking to her cat.
Now if you'll only attend kitty and to not talk so much.
I'll tell you all about my ideas about looking glass house.
This is Natasha gastric reading, and in this section of the book,
Alice is telling her cat like,
let's take a look at the difference between our world and that world right there
in the mirror. That's just the same as our drawing.
Only the things go the other way.
The books are something like our books. Only the words go the wrong way.
I know that because I've had at one of our books to the glass and then they hold
that when in the other room.
How would you like to live in looking Glass House Katie?
I one day think if you look in that
perhaps looking glass milk isn't good to drink. Perhaps
your milk isn't good to drink.
Why are you talking like that and what does that even mean? Well,
you just stick with me on this. I think I will make it perfectly clear. Okay.
This is a very, as it turns out, yes. Difficult scientific question. Yes.
They call it a [inaudible]. Okay. What this is Neil digraphs. Titan, Neil,
any I l d grass, small d e capital g. R a. S. S. E. Tyson.
He's an astrophysicist with the American Museum of Natural History,
also the director of the Hayden Planetarium. Cool. And what is that?
What is [inaudible]? Well, it's when you make a molecule,
there's no rule or law that says it has to be symmetric.
Neil says if you zoom into that bowl of milk,
which you're going to find is just chains of atoms that are stuck together in a
very particular shape and that shape, it could curl in a particular way.
So for example, if you have a spring and you turn your finger in the direction,
the spring, a spring, like a coil of coil, but like the spring out of your,
your click pen, pull out that spring. All right,
you have a pen right here under your pen. Pull it out and got spring out.
Here we go and look at the way the spring turns. Okay.
You get the spray and move your finger in the direction of her moving.
My is turning cluck.
Yes,
all the way up to the top. Okay.
That spring is that way in it's life.
Whether it's right side up or upside down, doesn't matter. Oh, always clockwise.
If you had a mirror, Chad, you happen to have something. Do I have a mirror? No.
[inaudible] take your phone, which has a reflected the shiny thing. Okay.
Put Your um, spring in front of the shiny surface of the phone. Okay.
Trace the spring with your finger and tell me which direction is your finger
going? Clockwise.
Yeah.
No, you already did this in the reflection. Oh,
in the phone to kind of tell that phone.
It's going the opposite way. Counter-Clockwise. Exactly.
And so now you have two oppositely turned springs.
You cannot turn one into the other.
They're built differently yet they are curiously identical.
So since molecules are just sequences of Adams,
imagine a molecule that has that shape.
If you put that molecule in front of the mirror, just the same as the spring,
you've got now two molecules built differently, but truly asley identical
[inaudible] kind of
like your right hand and your left hand,
your left hand and her right hand are related by a mirror image.
It's the same thing with these molecules. This is Marcello Glizer.
He's a physicist at Dartmouth college and according to Marcello,
this is how scientists talk about molecules. They call them [inaudible].
Sometimes we call it the hand in this,
sometimes you get a little more fancy and we call it Keyer Allity because Cairo
Kiros in Greek means hands and Marcello says,
if you look at pebbles or granted or cement inanimate stuff,
when you look at the shape of things inside,
it's a mixture of the two 50% lefthanded, 50% right-handed.
However, if you look at all the proteins are living things,
they are always lefthanded and no right-handed at all.
Really wife has chosen one over the other life as we know it has chosen.
When scientists look inside of living things, they, they always see it.
The molecules are pointing one way, right? So somehow,
and this is what's really amazing,
somehow life is shooting a very specific shape for the molecules to make up
stuff. That's correct. When you say life has chosen, well, that's good.
Let's take that sentence apart. Life,
meaning everything that is that we know of on earth, every living thing.
Hence my phrase, life as we know it. Everything. That's what that means.
The littlest things to the blue whale, that would be as we know,
the littlest clean. You think to the treat, the biggest tree,
the giant sequoia, that would be as we know, every protein in you,
dogs, trees, you name it. It's filled with left-handed building blocks. Yes.
It's called the [inaudible] of life. The Kira Allity of life life.
My friend is left hinted. Hmm.
That's pretty, that's a well, it feels cool, but let me just, uh,
like so what I mean, I don't want to put it bluntly, but I mean like w well,
other than the sheer surprise of having everything in life being shaped direct,
but I mean, what does it have to do with my life? Well, this bring one's life.
This brings the mirror thing.
This brings us back to the mirror mystery and Alice in the mirror milk. No, no,
because you, because you just told me that,
that the milk is left-handed because milk is in all kind of living cow. Yeah,
I remember you said that life has lefty [inaudible] so there can't be any
right-handed milks to the mirror. Milk doesn't exist.
Well that's because I forgot to tell you that scientists all the time
manufactured mirror molecules. They do. Yeah. Yeah.
They go into their laboratories and they synthetically make mirror molecules of
all kinds of things. Can they do milk mirror metal about milk in particular?
But I do know that when I talked to an Oxford professor, Marcus does a toy,
right? Yeah. He told me, if you take the atoms, which built caraway seeds,
which is the spice they use in Rye bread, take a mirror image of them.
Suddenly you get something which tastes of, Huh? It's what's put on Wrigley,
spearmint gum. And in fact, there are some very dramatic examples of this,
not just where the taste changes, but um, uh,
lessons might remember a story about the thalidomide drug.
In 1958, a West German pharmaceutical firm began marketing a new drug.
This is a new spot from the early 1960.
He said it though so effective and apparently harmless.
It quickly became one of the most widely used and prescribed drugs in west
Europe, illegitimate.
Before long pregnant women started taking it as a way to come.
Morning sickness and most of us, well, we know what happened next.
Every a woman President Kennedy in a press conference in this country,
I think must be aware that it's most important that they take this drug,
that they turn it in every citizen. Of course, I should be aware of the hazards.
All in all more than 12,000 children were born with arms and legs that were
shortened or deformed or completely missing.
The strange thing according to Marcus is that we now know they're the drunk.
When they first made the Lydia mine, it was old one hand,
let's say it was lefthanded. Yeah, and it did actually cure me.
What morning sickness and was completely harmless,
but somewhere along the way, thalidomide flip.
We don't know whether this was in the drug making process or after,
but we do know it's mirror image was incredibly poisonous.
So you know what this means jet but then in a show about symmetry,
what we've just discovered is that life itself is actually deeply asymmetric.
Yeah. Unlike love where we started the program back with um,
Aristophanes when it comes to life, you don't want to meet the other half.
Stay away man. [inaudible] anyhow,
that's well enough about me or no, no, no, no, no.
I think we can take this another step further. There is no further case.
I mean because
something about this chemistry reflections thing resonates for me with the
actual experience of standing in front of a mirror. How well, you know,
you look at that guy and you're like, Eh oof.
I mean we talked about this on stage actually in DC at the Shakespeare theater.
I remember when I asked you that personal question, do you want to do that?
Oh yes we do. Psychologically. Let me ask psychologically,
do you enjoy looking in the mirror?
Is that a question you wanted to ask me?
And I thought that's a private question.
Surely you know though that you are a,
the difference between your true self in your mirror self is not trivial.
Like true. What did you mean about my true self? I don't know.
Well I'm going to tell you this story now about a guy named John Walter. Oh,
the, with a little muster from Baltimore. From the movies. No,
that's John Waters. Walter. He's a computer programmer in neuro.
Shell paid him a visit recently cause back when he was in college he sorta
kindness switched places with the guy in the mirror. It was many years ago.
How old were you? 19. 19. So it was a long time ago.
We're talking late seventies here, but I was a, uh,
had already had some issues with the mirror. So let me set this up for you.
But thing to know about John is that as a kid he had a tough time.
Like so many of us, he would get bullied, beaten up on the playground.
It was no better when he got into his teens. And as a 19 year old,
his social life consisted of a series of stinging humiliations like the
following. I remember at the time there was a lot of um, kids hanging out.
You know, there was a crew of people like, you know, 20, 30,
40 kids would gather together at the aqua dock,
beautiful words of the aqueduct and go drink beers and smoke cigarettes.
You know, I've walked into the group, I care what's up. And it's like, yeah,
whatever. Roundly rejected.
And that according to John was normal, that that was normal, very normal.
Like people would say, what's that guy doing here?
Maybe he was like wearing the wrong plaid pants or had like, you know,
mismatch socks. There might be some whatever. Don't you emphasize this guy?
Nobody wants to be 19 and be the Yucky person. However,
the story that we'll follow centers on a revelation that John had that,
uh, began just as he was about to start his summer job for con Ed.
I was working for them as a painter and I had some pictures taken for
[inaudible] or ID photos. Yeah, there was an ID camera that had four lenses.
So when they took the negative, it was four of me. Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Like little squares, little squares, and I remember looking over and going,
why do I look so weird? Why do it look so weird?
Why do I have socks look so weird? Because here's the thing. I mean,
the John in the pictures was not the John that he knew himself to be that John
was kind of timid, nerdy, not cool.
Why do I look so weird in pictures? I look fine. What do you mean you look fine?
How do you know you look fine? Well, I thought I looked fine in the mirror.
You know when I looked at my course in the mirror, things on the left,
go to the right things on the right, go to the right, left. Wait a second.
That's when it hit him. Hit Him.
It's the hair part. It's the one.
It's the hair part. It's the what? It's the hair part.
I could do this all night. It's the hair part. What does that mean? It's the,
hey, I hear you. I hear you. That was that. Yeah, it's the hair part. Well,
in the picture, I saw a guy with a right hair apart in the mirror.
I seen a guy with a left hair part, essentially John [inaudible] look,
which part? Which side am I here? Part it on. It's your left. Your left.
My left. John Thought he was a leftie too.
He would stand in front of the mirror and the mirror would tell him he was
parting it to the left,
but in fact he was partying it to the right in real life.
Now the lefty guy in the mirror, he liked that guy.
I was fine with that guy who was cool. It was, there was nothing wrong with him,
but he realized he was the only person seeing that guy, so he thought,
Oh, let me put my hair on the other side. Let me essentially swap,
reel me for mirror me. It was one of these things where, yeah,
that looks really weird in the mirror, but at Betcha it looks good in real life.
Let me go find out. What did you do well that night
[inaudible]
it goes back to the aqueduct. Same posse is there, right in that same group.
Interesting enough,
had beat the crap out of me like three years earlier when I was in like ninth
grade, but there he was now with his hair parted on the left and he says,
this time things were different. Somebody offered him a beer. I was like, wow.
But the thing that I knew made it better was when I left,
I got goodbyes.
[inaudible]
come on. Come on. God. I look God for the first time. I'm, no,
this is ridiculous that you would tell me a story about a man who is having
social failures. University shifts is Arrow is remade. This is like,
it's his experience. It's very dull. It's too easy to dismiss,
but when you are ready, are you ready? I'm going to win you over.
You're not ready for this. I don't think you're ready. Are you ready?
If you are asking me to be [inaudible] I'm going to show you a picture right
now. All right. Okay. Have a look at, okay.
Who is that? It's Abraham Lincoln, our 16th president.
[inaudible] take him in. Taking deep into your consciousness. By the way.
This next part, you can see the
pictures@radiolab.org it's worth checking out his eyes, his nose, his mouth.
Pay attention particularly to the hair part. Okay,
now look what happens when you flip Abraham [inaudible].
Oh, that
there are no, no, no, no, no, no. Guys. Is this the same picture? Picture?
Go back to the other picture. Go. All right, here's a,
now we'll do the other one. Oh, you see, so weird. Now here's the thing.
This is what Abraham Lincoln would have seen when he looked in the mirror.
He would have seen this guy, not the other guy. The one we all see. Huh?
So there's something going on you. Would you not at least acknowledge me?
They find this big leap. Awesome. Yes. Okay. With your permission,
Mr Sinek,
I will now rejoin John Who's about to get married and had three babies.
He said after, after he switched this part,
it just kept getting better and better and better all summer long.
He was suddenly invited to all of these parties,
but the very same people that used to beat him up and for the first time,
he says, I was clearly one of them. Now, whether you're not you buy that,
this is in fact because of his hair that's on you. Okay,
but let's fast forward just a little bit. The next summer,
this would have been 1979 yeah,
nine 79 John sitting in front of the TV and on comes.
Good evening. This is a special night for me. The President Jimmy Carter,
make it a speech about how our nation is in a deep
fuck.
Why have we not been able to get together as a nation to resolve a serious
energy problem? The malaise speech,
you know that that infamous countries in malaise,
it's clear that the true problems of our nation,
a much deeper,
deeper than gasoline lines or energy shortages, deeper even
that inflation or recession. Yeah. As you know,
I'm sure you remember a lot of people would criticize Jimmy Carter for making
the speech because he's up there admitting flaws and they were like,
come on Mr President.
Don't be weak man up John meanwhile is sitting in front of the TV and he's
thinking, dude, you've got to change your hair part.
[inaudible] until I wrote them cause I wrote to him, I wrote to him with Ac.
You said, wait, wait, wait. I think I just said,
I think you should change your hair. Pardon? On the on the left.
I did myself and found it to be much more powerful, much, much more successful.
And um, that six letter, I so wish I did. I don't have it. Um,
and then about six weeks later, boom, he twitched. He switched. No, he,
John wrote him a letter and President Carter switched. No,
it might not have been John's letter that didn't have no evidence.
Think about how much I like what's involved in a president switching is here.
There are focus groups. There are prayer meetings.
There's so much thought that goes into the, did anyone actually record this? Uh,
yes they did. I will. I will now read you a journalistic account from no,
no. A periodical. There you go. Washington book right there.
You see Bam right there. Oh Man. Newsweek,
May 7th, 1979 at first, photographers thought they had their negatives reversed,
but no,
Jimmy Carter has changed the partners here from the right side to the left.
The Washington press score demanded an explanation. Right.
I remember that. You know,
as opposed to John who changes his here and then all the girls giving beers.
This guy, he was running against a haired man,
Megan. And it didn't matter. So he just, you know, we got crushed. Right.
You know what? Forget smart. Forget the executive branch. Yeah.
Stay with me now.
I was with John and he was showing me pictures of congressmen and of celebrities
and uh, I noticed something peaking out at the bottom of the pile.
I see peeking out underneath the stack of photos as a superman. Yeah.
Can you show me a picture of Superman looking mighty in his superman suit?
Notice how he parts his hair. Yeah. It's a little bit on there. On that side.
Yeah. No, and this is Clark cat. Uh,
and as we know from the movies clerk, Kent is fumbling sort of a dork.
I was at first, really nervous about tonight.
So somebody made that movie,
maybe explicitly intuitively understood something about the difference that
maybe you know the right parts at one thing. But Clark Kent,
the left part said something about superman. In fact,
there is a scene in the movie where Clark kids were running down an alley.
He's about to turn into superman.
He pulls his shirt open to reveal the s and literally mid-stride his hair goes
and turns from the hood to the left.
So you're saying that sophisticated popular cultural motion picture manufactures
at at least two presidents have been persuaded to this position at this very
moment on a Saturday night. That is what I'm saying. All right.
Well for arguments sake that, what would you say, I hate to get into this,
any paper explains the difference between putting the power of your hair on the
left hand or the right hand. Well, if you ask John,
what he'll say is that the left hair part emphasizes strength and logic because
it draws your attention to the logical and more masculine side of your face,
your brain. Cause it's a left brain kind of thing. But I, I don't really know.
Okay.
So I decided I would actually take this seriously and figure out how to feel
about it. So I call it this guy. Good. I jet. It's a nice name is Mike Nichols.
Oh, from the graduate. There's the Mike People. Very good.
A psychology professor in Australia is an expert in symmetry. That Mike Nichols.
Yes. I ran him through John's theory. Have you ever seen the superman movies?
Some of the earlier ones. I think,
you know how Clark Kent's hair is parked to the right and then [inaudible] ran
through the whole thing. Yeah. Clark's on the rain.
Maybe he's weeks you've met lev, maybe he's you stronger, more assertive, right.
Is there anything to that? Anything at all? Um, yeah, I mean possibly,
you know, um, that's, um,
uh, but, but, but see,
he didn't say this, which is interesting. In focusing on the left.
John May be picking up on a particular bias that we,
human beings have to our left side. For instance,
here's an experiment that he and his colleagues didn't like.
A snapshot of someone's face, um,
at baseline when they're showing no emotion blank face and then get them to try
to look as happy or sad as I could take happy guy and overlay him on to no
expression guy and almost like a come to a map.
You could actually look at the amount of change,
amount of muscle movement and that it occurred,
which you will see if you measure the muscle movement in millimeters on each
side of the face.
You'll see that the smile curves a few extra millimeters on the left side of the
face. He says this is nearly always the case, always on the left side.
What is really telling you is that when somebody smiles or when they frown or
whatever, they're doing it slightly more strongly on the left side of the face.
Now, if this is the case,
that our left side is sort of saying more emotionally than our right side,
then if you think about the mirror, it's kind of a discombobulating thing,
you know, cause it's taken your left, which is sort of broadcasting emotion,
flipping it to your right, you're seeing yourself, you're all mixed up.
You don't know which part of you is where you're. So you're saying,
because I tend to address you as my attention on your left side,
unbeknownst to me. And your left side is actually flipped over to your right.
Said I don't, I, it's a where are we sort of exactly. But John has, uh,
has developed a solution to this problem.
We'll take this one apart now.
Makes and sells his own very special mirrors right out of his home.
And this is where you make everything to get goes into the mirrors made here.
Um, you see here, this is the machine that cuts the mirror.
He buys these giant sheets of reflective glass and he slices them into little
pieces,
clunk. And then I snap it. Now for each mirror,
uh, this is the key. He uses two pieces of mirror glass instead of one.
What he'll do is he'll take these two pieces and he will place them together at
a at right angles to mirrors at right angles like exactly at right angles.
It has to be 90.0 degrees and let's just push this up a little bit.
That's still not enough. And he gets when he finally gets it right,
which can take hours. What he'll have is his v shaped mirror. He'll stand it up,
put it in a box, and then Voila.
What you have is a mirror that shows you a mirror image of a mirror image of you
takes the normally flipped guy that you'd see in the mirror,
re flips him so that what you are seeing is essentially,
well for the first time in a mirror you see yourself as other people see you.
Okay, so there you go. So what does this that you have in your, this is,
this is a true mirror. This is a to the 12 inch model. And so when you like,
this is actually what I look like at touch. You're right, I see.
It's actually on the right side. Oh my God, I'm that crazy. That's crazy.
It is surprisingly weird to see yourself this way.
I feel like my nose is going the wrong way. Yeah.
I never knew my nose went that way and this little flair in my eyebrows is on
the wrong side or the right side as it were.
John claims that many a fair number. I probably would put you in this bunch.
My cohost, when they stand in front of this mirror,
they a freak out many of them because they,
it's just their perception is shaken up a little bit. In fact,
he sometimes takes his mirrors to these festivals and he will sort of set them
up and have people look at themselves and then fill out comment cards
afterwards. You know what I mean? If you look at some of the comments,
you know it's like monster,
I am
monster anymore.
What did he say? I am a, I am
may
monster in your mirror.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
to break, we go. If you want any more information on anything you heard,
go to our website,
radiolab.org or if you want to see those incredible pictures of Ape Lincoln,
that's where they are. Yes, right. And subscribe to our podcast there as well.